hey what's up guys my name is a Jonah
welcome to episode 63 of game
programming alright so today we're going
to talk about collision detection yeah
that's right
collision detection probably the single
most heavily requested topic for me to
cover ever has been collision detection
and I can kind of get why like I'm not
gonna be like oh I've no idea was so
easy but um I do kind of get why you
guys you know would want would want to
you know I guess learn how to do it
obviously is very important to making
games but also in my opinion is probably
one of the most hardest easier things to
do in game programming because it's kind
of hard to to visualize like if you were
to go out and be like alright I'm not
gonna look at any resources I'm just
gonna I'm just gonna make collision
detection from scratch logical in my
head and I'm going to write it down on
piece of paper and then implement it
into my code and the answer is it'll
probably work right unless you're you
know kind of I don't how to put this in
a polite way unless you're not educated
let's just say it'll probably work right
but it's probably not going to be the
most efficient way to I'm actually
handle collision I remember the first
time that I actually made collision
detection I didn't look at any resources
I just said logical in my head alright
well you know if this part of this
square collides with this square you
know if this part of this square exceeds
the x-bow marie's of another square you
know and do the same for every other
corner pretty much if that happens then
there is collision and then but now then
we've got the other issue of we've
detected collision but there has to be
collision response right we've detected
collision but we have to come we have to
kind of react to it you know what I mean
so detecting collision is one thing it's
pretty easy to do actually it's just you
know if if this is inside this other
object then we've got a problem you know
that's that's a collision but then
there's also the aspect of it that okay
we can't move in that direction now how
do we make the play and not be able to
move in a certain direction based on if
there's collision there a lot and again
the answer is extremely simple and it's
literally one line of code I'm not even
going to lie it's
one line of code that is the most like
that is that is pretty much that's
basically agent detection right there
but we're not actually going to do that
we're going to do a bit of a more
advanced way and I'll show you guys a
simple way first by the way so that you
guys can wrap your head around how
roughly works and then I'll lead into
the more advanced way but um it's just
more accurate that's why we're going to
do any more advanced why not just
because I want to but um it's yeah it's
it's actually not that hard it it
probably sounds hard and feels hard but
it's not that hard
ok so right now what we've got in our
game is we've got these things here all
right and let me quickly okay good I was
worried I would run out of disk space
because I always sometimes do that when
I'm recording but it's alright I got
three point six five gig left on my own
moment on my main drive ok so I'm what
we've got right now is what kind of just
prancing all over this all over these
tiles and remember we've actually set
these tiles through this but I know this
is this wall I guess these walls we've
actually set them to be solid so if we
just get out of this we expand a little
um level thing our tile folder and we've
got a bunch of tiles here like Sinan's
in spawn level we've got wall tile and
in wall tile you know public boolean
solid it returns true so in other words
that is true if we look at something
like grass tile that actually doesn't
have a solid method I guess it doesn't
have a solid method because by default
if it doesn't have a solid method it
looks like it looks at the the
superclass and you can see here that it
returns false right
same with floor tile but wall tile and
hedge tile they actually return true and
solid and that's actually breakable but
I don't know we so you have an implement
and implementer that yet but um yeah so
they're solid right now hedging wall
tiles are solid so that's that's the
first step right the first step in
collision detection is actually to
identify what tiles are solid and what
are not solid why does my mouse drop out
of my house
stop working sometimes that's better I
don't turn up for anyway um yeah right
so the first step is actually defining
which tiles you're you can't pass
through in which tiles you can pass
through so this tile obviously we can't
pass through right we've set it to
return true so in other words it is
solid we've set it to be solid now let's
go into our mob class right and if you
guys remember the mob class is the class
that actually handles the move method so
in other words if we want to move a mob
if we want to move an object well thank
you if we want to move a mob then we
have to you know that's that's where
that move method comes from if we want
to move a mob we go through the mob
class this is this is how it happens and
we've even set up a temporary collision
thing here right we've pretty much just
laid down all the groundwork for this
we've said that if there is no collision
so if collision equals false right this
is a it's referring to this bullying
here by the way it's currently returning
false but if it equals false then yeah
let's advance in those directions but if
there is a collision then you cannot
move so that's kind of collision
response already done right and that's
obviously a very simple way of doing it
but that's kind of how it works all
right so how do we actually you know
stop ourselves from moving through those
collidable tiles yeah so how do we
actually you know stop a player from
being able to pass through these tiles
the way we actually do that is obviously
we need to run the algorithm here in um
the collision method right because
basically if we return true for this
collision then we're just not going to
be able to move and you consider here
whether we just we can't move anywhere
right because collisions returning true
but what we want to be able to do is
only return true and certain cases so in
other words we want to control this this
boolean value here right I'm just going
to call it solid equals false for now
and let's return solid all right so what
I've done here is I've just created a
variable out of it but um we want to be
able to control this boolean we want to
be able to say that based on where we
are moving
- you know if that tile is solid and
look don't let us get into that tile
because it's solid right
so what we kind of want to say is that
if I'm moving this way hypothetically
well I am actually moving this way but
if I'm moving this way and I get to here
then let's look ahead of where I'm
moving which is this tile but wait that
tile is solid so we can't move further
return false and that's the idea
honestly that is the idea so we want to
be like if we move that way then you
know don't don't let us go there and the
other way that we can actually um
picture this as well a lot of people
make a mistake of saying if the tile
that I'm currently on is a solid tile
don't let me move and that doesn't
really work when you think about it
because it's like well if you're already
on a solid tile like you shouldn't even
be there in the first place if you're
already there it's kind of too late like
you already on it so we I'm not gonna
let you out of it now it's a solid title
you can't move now so we want to kind of
look ahead and how do we tell how do we
look how do we look ahead right that's
that's another question how do we look
ahead and if you see over here actually
the direction in which we move is
defined by x and y all right they are
either negative 1 0 or 1 and negative 1
means we're moving you know in axis case
we're moving left 0 means we're not
moving anywhere and Y means we're moving
right so come over here right we've
already got a way of actually looking
forward XA and Y it tells us which
direction we're going in so in other
words over here if we just simply add XA
to X we're gonna get the tile that we're
about to be in right right so one thing
I'm going to do is actually feed in X a
and Y as parameters into this collision
method because I want to be able to use
those variables to figure out where
we're going and the tiler where future
will that will be in the future so that
we can run a check throw it and say if
it's you know if it's solid then return
false or I'll return true so over here
the way that we kind of checked that is
and I'm trying to break
because this is one line of code and I
want to explain as much as I can but
basically if level get I'll right and
what level target all is is it returns
to us all the properties of a particular
tile so if level door get tile right and
which tile we're getting here we're
getting tile X plus X a and y plus y a
so in other words X is the current
position of where we are in terms of X
and XA is where we're going to move in
terms of X so our future location in
terms of X right what same with Y right
Y our current location and Y and Y is
where we're going to move in terms of Y
so up or down and that's the obviously
left and right left all right so if
level Doggett tile and we're getting
this particular tile here if it is solid
right then solid pinkles true oops
and that ladies and gentlemen is
collision detection honestly so let's
run this and see what we get okay so we
get a crash that's okay the reason we
get a crash makes me forgot to mention
this was that we don't actually have
level setup right if we actually control
click on level it leads to this and
obviously level doesn't equal anything
so we get a nullpointerexception
what we need to do is actually
initialize the end level inside the
entity class so what I like to do is
make a method called in it stands for
initialized right and all will do here
is it will actually back parameter the
level object parameter so this dot level
equals level and that's it right so in
other words the parameter that we that
we will feed in here will be set to this
and this of course we use here so let's
go back to our game Java class that's
our main class and over here you see
that we actually do have a player right
here and player those here mob so what
we can do here is we can say player dot
in it and we can actually set level
equal to this level and of course that
level is actually equal to level dot
spawn so in other words it is equal to
something
and if we run this now where I get a
crash all right so let's check this out
ready ready ready oh we pass right
through it
now why did that happen I wonder now the
reason that that happened is actually
pretty simple I love how I just kind of
mess with you guys though you're
probably expecting it so if we actually
check out what this value equals so if
we just quickly print out X plus X a and
just for good measure
we'll also print out y plus y a we bring
out those variables when we move we
actually get oh wow look how big they
are ten thousand and two 200 why they so
big and there isn't they're so big as
they're returning it in terms of pixels
not tiles and if we go to get tile
method you know we're actually looking
at a particular tile right so tiles
obviously is in terms of tiles is
actually in terms of tablet what do we
even hang on it where is tile set
exactly um it'll be this form well yeah
so here tiles is head to width times
height which at the moment is 64 by 64
so course that frickin exceeds it also
actually 64 by 64 but anyway it's set to
tile level precision right but we're
talking about pixel level precision here
clearly so what we actually need to do
is convert it back into tolerable
precision and the way that we can do
that is pretty simple we can um we can
simply grab X plus XA put in brackets
and divided by you know how big our
tiles are which 16 that's it that is how
simple it is
so now take two right now if we do this
okay first of all let's carry this
printing thing but actually just to
prove a point if I do quickly copy that
and put it here
all right then you can see that look at
that we're now entire level position so
if I go yeah look at that I cannot go
there I go down look at that I can't
can't go down um if we actually come up
here as well so I can prove to you how
it works if we go here all of it out we
cannot go past here right if we go that
we can't come to conquer there clunk why
there look at that
it's working brilliantly now one thing
that is there's two kind of problems
with this collision and why I wouldn't
just leave it like this this is basic so
you guys can kind of see how it works
right but um one thing that we can't do
is if we are colliding here we can't
actually move up and down while we're
holding that key right it stops us from
doing that and the reason it stops us
from doing that is because what we've
already collided so as long as we're
trying to go that way we can't move but
what we want to kind of do is say that
okay the collision is horizontal so let
us still move vertically that's one
thing we need to do the other thing we
need to do is actually make this a bit
more precise so you can see that we've
don't really have control here in fact
that didn't even work because we weren't
in the right place as you can see here
yeah so there's a few kind of quirks
with this thing obviously the basis is
it works fine but I want to I like to
make it just a bit more accurate and we
can actually do that next time and I
promise that the next episode will be
released in like a few days it won't be
like a few weeks a couple weeks will be
a couple days but yeah that's basically
how collision works
so I suggest that you guys are kind of
go through that and see if you can
understand it fully if you guys do come
up with with a solution by the way I um
I actually have a subreddit called the
chair no big surprise but um it's over
here all right and I do go through this
occasionally but people post stuff here
like I don't like alternatives actually
haven't read that obviously but you can
see most of these links of purple so hey
I do read it in fact I've even uploaded
this link probably haven't helped them
weather
but anyway the point is this is this is
a subreddit and what you guys to know is
you can obviously submit posts and if
you submit a post you can share your way
of collision detection or if you've got
a problem you can also submit that
obviously and people will help you out
because people here are really nice
unlike me so yeah anyway the point is if
you guys do come up with a um with a
night with it with what you think is a
more accurate way of actually dealing
with closure and post it here
you know I'll check it out and maybe
other people can check it out as well
and maybe they'll share their ways and
maybe we can get an get an even better
way of handling collision than what I've
got right now obviously next time
regardless of if any posts actually
occur I'll actually share with you guys
the way that I obviously make this more
accurate and that's probably the way
I'll do it anyway because it works 100%
of the time and it's really really nice
but um that's rough collision detection
just because I wanted to bring it down
bring it down a notch for you guys so
that you could really understand
collision in one line of code because it
is kind of confusing to wrap your head
around but that's kind of how it works
anyway guys we'll see you guys next time
on episode 64 again a couple days
because I've actually got a week off uni
now because of Easter yeah anyway if you
guys enjoyed the video please hit the
like button and I'll see you guys next
time guys
you